- La tendance prend
de l'ampleur et dérange.
Des vidéos de comptes anonymes
vues par des milliers d'abonnés
avec un titre commençant
par le mot "J'expose",
suivi d'une vidéo montrant,
par exemple, la personne
"la plus 2 watts de l'école"
ou encore "la fille
qui consomme à 13 ans".
D'autres titres vont
plus loin et identifient
l'école de l'élève visé.
- C'est de la méchanceté
gratuitement puis, bien,
c'est chiant, là. Moi, je suis
un peu tannée d'en voir!
- Si tu as pas l'autorisation
de la personne pour "poster"
sa face, c'est pas... correct.
- Je comprends pas
le but de faire ça.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Et toutes les vidéos
contiennent la même
trame sonore...
♪ ♪ ♪
... celle de ce rappeur
qui en déplore l'utilisation
depuis sa Côte d'Ivoire natale.
FIOR 2 BIOR, rappeur
- Je demande au moins
un minimum de respect
pour autrui, au fait,
c'est très important.ant.ant.an.
- Plusieurs ont dénoncé
ces publications; cette future
enseignante l'a fait sur TikTok,
coach en improvisation
- Je pense que les gens
devraient vraiment signaler
ces comptes-là,
absolument que ça cesse parce
que c'est de l'intimidation,
mais à grande portée. Tout
le monde est capable d'avoir
accès ses-là, puis...
À l'époque, l'intimidation,
je pense que ça s'arrêtait
quand les gens rentraient
chez eux le soir, mais là,
ça les poursuit même le soir.
- La tendance s'est
répandue rapidement.
Elle a débuté par les vidéos dee
deux utilisatrices francaises,
puis elle s'est installée
au Québec la semaire.
De quelle façon intervenir
auprès des élèves ciblés?
CAMILLE ALLOING, prof. Dép. de
comm. sociale et publique, UQAM
- Les interroger sur leurs
pratiques : ont-ils conscience
de ce que la plateforme...
une plateforme comme TikTok
va faire de leurs publications?
Est-ce qu'ils comprennent
ce que ça peut provoquer chez
les personnes qu'ils mettent
ne? Alors,ne? Alors,ne? Alors,nt
positif, drôle, c'est une chose;
quand ça peut devenir négatif
et du harcèlement,
c'en est une autre.
- Selon TikTok, de nombreux
comptes ont été supprimés
dans les derniers jours. Ici Mé,
Radio-Canada, Mon